if you can find what is your passion if
you find what you love we can never say
businesses as big because if you
passionate about everything is person
[Music]
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up belief nation it seven I am sick but
I still believe in you and this channel
is still designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
cup of tea and sip on today's message
find your true passion over to you Oprah
Winfrey also if you want to know what
Oprah and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you there
real work is to figure out where your
power base is if you can find what is
your passion if you find what you love
you never get tired or if you do get
tired if you you're fueled by the energy
of your work and you know what you're
supposed to do bhai how it feels and so
you know if you're doing the right thing
if it feels like it's right to you and
when you hit the thing that feels right
you know it's right because it gives you
your juice and you know it's right
because you would do it for nothing you
would do it for nothing and find a way
to be able just to do it in order to be
able to continue that's how you know
you're doing what you supposed to be
doing I've got a special bonus clip for
you that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is your true passion for me
it's helping entrepreneurs I was up late
last night helping entrepreneur I should
have been to bed it was bad for my body
but good for my soul what is your true
passion
no leaving the comments below
we can never say business is his
business because if you passionate about
everything is personal right you tell me
so with me when I do songs with people I
don't do it to be like oh I'm how to do
right now I'm not charging them for
versus you know like when I when I come
into New York and we do a press run I'm
calling you like yes what you need I'm
coming you know because that's what it's
all about is my love is not about who we
getting out of it I don't do music cuz
it make me rich you know that's the plus
you know I would've been doing this if
it was free yeah I get free music on all
the time so what is the success success
is not about how much money you have in
the bank success is simply about how
many lives you've been able impact
positively and you know I tell our
children all the time is that you know
the best way you will ever know that you
become successful is the day you become
humble because if you have iota of
arrogance left in you that you still
trying to prove something to someone or
yourself that means you're not
successful success comes from when you
don't have to tell someone you know who
I am right you just be yourself and you
go out and do things that you care about
and what is it that you're passionate
about what is it that you're willing to
die for and then you live for it what if
that was the only had everything in life
what would you do and if you do that
today and that's how you constantly
focus and find your passion to do things
that when you're the fourth generation
as we said that new intro of reversing
per item was there any doubt in your
mind that you were going to go into the
family business
actually no it's what I've always wanted
to do I've always been a fan of
wrestling and WWE in particular and
especially growing up watching my father
who was the chairman CEO and also a
commentator on the show and I was just
enthralled you know business
conversation at the dinner table and and
listening to the stories that were
getting built and the characters and
meeting them and seeing them actually my
first WWE live event I was about three
years old and I went walking backstage
and I'll never forget it all of a sudden
these kids came running at me screaming
terrified and I couldn't imagine what
was happening my parents were down the
hallway and then here
was george the animal' steele who had
basically so much hair on his back it
was like fern he his tongue was green
and he was in character lumbering
towards me and I then screamed at the
top of my lungs and virtually ran up my
father's leg and buried my head in his
neck but I noticed he was laughing my
father the great defender and then he
introduced me to George the animal
Steele who was also known as Jim Myers a
schoolteacher and that was my first
inkling into the world of WWE if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would become like a little beacon
if you want to learn more about Oprah's
inspiring story I highly recommend the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy continue to believe and
I'll see you there for the first six
years of my life I knew somehow that my
life would be different and it would be
better